when it comes to dating i tell women
it's okay to be feminine it's okay no no
you don't have to pick the restaurant
you don't have to offer to pay the man
knows what he's getting himself into
he's prepared
we know what this is it's a dance and
it's okay now it doesn't mean you never
reciprocate
other way but let him core to you let
him get give him the opportunity
to show you why he's worthy of you
because that's what he wants to show you
don't say i don't need you to help pick
the wine i can pick my
you know what it's wine unless it's
chardonnay because i really hate
chardonnay
it's okay you're not you're not gonna
die from the fact that he chose this
cabernet sauvignon
just let him do it it's okay he wants to
give to you
in fact a great way to turn man on is to
ask him to help you
i kind of feel like this a lot of this
has to do with
at some point there was a fracture in
our society that resulted in
two different factions i guess right we
have the culture war today a lot of
people trying to figure out if it's left
versus right nationalist versus
globalist or authoritarian whatever and
when
i when i hear stories like this you as a
guy you never know
what ideology the woman holds and so
are you even allowed to make a move on
the woman as it is so you mentioned the
guys want to court you
well if you go to like a sports pub
you're probably going to bump into a guy
who knows nothing about critical theory
and feminism
it'll probably start hitting on you if
you're in a big city though and you go
to like a hipster bar
the guys won't go anywhere near you
because you're not allowed to
right so i mean you you look at that
video that went viral
you see it was uh 10 hours of walking in
new york as a woman remember that one
oh yeah so some of these things that
were depicted as wrong
was a guy saying howdy or like nice day
or
how are you doing and and hello
it's terrible that's if that if that's
if if if that's the message we're
getting from mainstream media then what
guy is going to risk his reputation his
career
and then even if he does get married get
divorced at some point
and then just lose everything and his
kids society is currently being set up
in a way that is telling men to do
everything they can not to get married
and they're happy
no responsibility they can sit around
playing video games all day i think it's
bad for the spirit
and in the long term the purpose and and
you know of our society but i think this
is just another factor that's resulting
in the collapse
of american culture and western culture
yeah over i don't know what it is i
don't want to say it's that we have too
much freedom or anything like that
that we can choose to just self-gratify
right you know we are a wealthy
successful
country so we can play video games all
day we can drink mountain dew and eat
taco bell and have to worry about a
thing i don't think that it's our choice
you know
our ability to do to do these things i
think it's the pressures of of
uh it's it's man i go back to like uh
what we were mentioning earlier
with doubling the workforce in a short
amount of time
as soon as people were like you know we
should have women in the workplace if
they so choose
it became part of a movement that they
should be in the workplace right
all of a sudden then you double the
workforce
without increasing demand and everyone's
competing and wages are dropping
then they say okay we gotta have a
minimum wage to guarantee it but there's
still not enough jobs so then some
people don't have jobs
once that happens and everyone's wages
are depressed there's a lot of other
factors as to why it happens
you have all of these factors building
up over decades
that result in a generation of people
who are not
compatible in terms of long-term
relationships and families
yeah no it's it's depressing and it's
sad and
and i think that we are too focused on
the narratives of how
to be a woman means you know to be
president united states
to be vice president united states to be
the top echelon of everything
and um i mean i all the power to every
woman and i certainly strive in my own
career my own life to be the
to reach my potential and i'm so
grateful to live in a country that
enables me
to do that but
the truth is different than the
narrative and the truth
is that most women become mothers most
women want to be mothers which isn't to
say
that there aren't women who are child
free by choice and they honor and
champion the choice
everybody should do what they need and
want to do
the issue is that men are feeling and i
hear what you're saying
why should i get off the couch first of
all i can
sext her and because she likes me and
wants my attention she'll sex
back so i don't even need to take her
out on a date
right and if i take her out on a date i
mean she's going to make me feel like
i'm not a man because she's going to
like not
let me participate in i don't think
that's an issue no
no i mean it maybe maybe it depends on
generation
you know so maybe older guys really want
that
i i me personally i've never really
cared much for
if a woman was like i want this i bet
whatever i don't care like right no no
would she right
so what women want
so women modern women want old-fashioned
romance
now many feminists will say no that's
not true
but that's really what women want and
partly because they
are working so hard they
are working hard in their career those
who have careers right they're working
hard there
but also they are nurturers
so they're working on their friendships
and their girlfriends that
call them upset they're working it makes
you their parents are okay that their
siblings are okay their neighbors are
okay they they do
a lot because of their own innate sense
of taking care
of people and taking care of the
children in their life etc
and they want to know when they're with
a guy
that all he has to do is just say meet
me
at this restaurant at 7 00 p.m
that that is like such a thing that
women want it makes them feel so good
so guys like i don't care if she picks a
place like whatever whatever she wants
like
i mean if she is a place like around the
corner from her that you i don't
no care it's funny uh it's it starts to
sound to me
like feminism is one of the worst
possible things for women in the long
run
and one of the best possible things for
guys in the long run from a very like
what's the right way from a from a sort
of mathematical perspective
so guys used to have to work really hard
back breaking labor you know wiping the
sweat off their brow covered in dirt
going down to the coal mines
now they've got women working to support
themselves
so the guys don't have to worry about it
anymore women are
not have they're not making the same
demands of men in terms of you know
sexual relationships it's just go on
tinder and the guy guys have to worry
about it
so now guys don't have to work they've
got all the time in the world because
they don't have a biological clock in
the same way as a woman so they're
sitting back with their feet up playing
video games without a stress in the
world
i'm being hyperbolic sure but their
women are working they're worried about
how long that how much time they have
where they can
you know in order to have a family right
they're stressing about how to find the
right guy
and guys are just sitting there swiping
on tinder while they're watching you
know
porn yeah yeah yeah
so they're swiping on tinder and
watching porn at the same time
yeah and they're like what am i worried
about right i've got friends
you know i grew up i grew up
skateboarding and all of these guys
don't care about anything they will they
will work a minimum wage job
if it means that you can have 10 people
in a two-bedroom apartment
so they can work only a couple days it's
a hundred bucks a month for rent and
they can skate the rest of the day
that's all they care about yeah and i
look at the the guys who grew up in you
know
like around me from my neighborhood and
everything a few of them you know have
families
but not by plan you know what i mean and
then everyone else who kind of planned
and worked and went to college
they're sitting back with their feet up
making tons of money they have careers
and they're not worried at all and you
talk to them and they're like i don't
know you know
when i'm 40 maybe i'll find a 25 year
old they're not worried at all right
right no and also because they don't
have a biological clock and all of that
and but you know you are a prime example
of a guy who
decided that wasn't enough and you
manned up your own life
look at what you're doing right you're
the guy who said no this
is not fulfilling for me to only
skateboard or sit on the couch or or
tinder porn watch right
you decided that no i have potential i
have great potential i don't even know
my
potential because i haven't even started
it yet and then you did
and you're still going and you're still
going you're building a media empire
right
you're a man and that's sexy to women it
is not
sexy for a guy to be sitting on the
couch
you know swiping on tinder women don't
find that appealing
and they're and it works for them well
it doesn't it doesn't there's also a lot
of men who are depressed
a lot of men who you know unfortunately
commit suicide
a lot of men who are overdosing um who
are aimless
and they're getting older and they don't
know how to get out of it
and i'm hoping one of the silver linings
of covid
is that many were forced to be alone
that there was no other
choice maybe maybe life needs a little
more meaning
and again that's where a partner a woman
or man in his life can help him
get there thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
timcast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time